Well, hello there. Welcome wherever and
whenever you might be watching,
especially if this is your first time
with us, Adventist or otherwise.
My name is Miles. Glad that you could
join us. I got an extra big tea tonight.
You'll notice a lot bigger than uh usual
because it is going to be a long night,
folks. I know that Ellen White would be
disappointed, but I'm drinking tea
regardless. Now, a couple weeks ago, Dr.
Christopher Sernaki hosted
Dr. Jud Lake, one of my former
professors
over on the uh Christ Jesus Ministries
YouTube channel to respond to yours
truly. I was intrigued when I saw this,
not because it was in response to me
particularly, but because I know Dr.
Lake personally and I reached out to him
some months back regarding having him
come on to answering Adventism, not to
debate but to answer some questions
regarding his book Ellen White under
fire. This is what I sent him folks.
So this was on October 6, 2023.
I said, "Hi, Dr. Lake. Hope all is well.
I was wondering if you would be open to
having a discussion
on your book, Ellen White Under Fire.
I'm currently reading it. I'd love to
record it and upload on our answering
Adventism platform. As you recall, I'm
not an Adventist and and am completely
transparent about my views like I was
when I was your student. However, I do
find great uh great benefit in seeking
to have dialogue with SDA uh pastors,
theologians, scholars to showcase a
balanced view and let Adventists share
their perspective. I am not seeking a
confrontational style discussion or
debate,
but again would love to ask you some
questions about your book to let others
hear your perspective. Is this something
that you would consider?
You would have complete access to the
recording and nothing would be chopped
up,
spliced or twisted.
Again, strictly would be about giving
you as an SDA thought leader and a a
former professor of mine an opportunity
to share where you are coming from. I'll
be honest, it's pretty difficult to get
Adventists that are willing to do so.
Yet, we receive constant complaints from
Adventists that we never seek out
discussions to let Adventists share
their perspective.
Now, to no surprise, he declined. Notice
why
he says in part, and I've redacted some
of the information obviously because
well, it's not pertinent and people
don't need to see it. But this is his
response as to the interview.
I have historically avoided going on
these types of venues because they
always want to fight with me and I've
already said what I wanted to say in my
writings,
particularly in my book that you're
reading. I prefer to address challenges
in writing or podcast where I can be as
precise as I need to be. At least that's
been my policy so far. Having said that,
I'd be glad to meet with you when you're
here on October 24 and field your
questions without
the recording.
End of email.
So, like I said, some of the information
is redacted because it's not relevant
and I just needed to show his response.
But, Dr. Lake, I said this wasn't going
to be a debate.
I actually stated it twice. I would
simply ask questions, let you answer,
move to the next question, repeat.
I said all footage would be available to
you unedited. No funny business at my
own expense even wouldn't even be
digitally at my own expense. I would
come to where you are your office and
the discussion could take place there in
person like we've done I don't know how
many times. So you can see there's no
strings attached to me. I've got no crew
of people hiding you know doing some
nefarious behavior. And the whole
purpose of having it recorded was stated
two times. To meet the requests of SDAs
who feel as though this platform
misrepresents them. Doing it unrecorded
doesn't allow for that. There's no need
for me and you to just have a dialogue
behind the scenes. We've done that I
don't know how many times. Yet you
turned it down and instead he went on to
a different platform to do a response
video to the platform he was invited to
be on a few months prior.
So apparently you didn't feel like you
said all that you needed to say, did
you, Dr. Lake? Because the largest
portion of your guys's response was on
the subject that I inquired about.
But I think you and I both know the real
reason you don't want the interaction on
record.
Because despite the claim to saying what
you needed in your book already,
you'd still have the discussion you
said, but off record.
So I commented on their response video
after watching it
and this is what I said.
Fascinating.
So Dr. Lake turned down the opportunity
to come on to answering Adventism and
discuss and instead
remains in the echo chamber.
Let's have a public-f facing discussion
gents.
It's on the 12th of this month. to which
Christopher Sernaki responded with this.
Thank you very much for writing out your
comment. Other comments on this video
have been less than civil and so as per
Christ Jesus Ministries LLC policy,
we've not published them, including
comments favorable to the broadcast.
However, your comment had a bid for
connection at the end, and that is
something that I appreciate. Miles, I've
had the great honor and privilege of
learning from non-sethday Adventist
Christian scholars. The Christ Jesus
Ministries LLC channel has even featured
scholars who are critical of of the
Seventh Day Adventist Christian faith in
their publications. We do not have a
problem with open and honest critiques
of the Seventh Adventist Christian
Church. Thus, to be objective, one
cannot call Christ Jesus Ministries LLC
an echo chamber. I have no interest in
defaming your character or attacking
your person. Rather, it's my hope that
Christians of different denominations
and religious persuasions can have good
faith dialogues. In fact, in all phases
of production, the fil uh uh to film
this video, Professor Lake did did speak
well of you and inform me that he had
sent you an email.
Yes. And we just looked at that email,
Christopher, and I made it clear it
would be a good faith dialogue, not a
debate, to ask questions on record for
SDAs to not make the charge that
answering Adventism is an echo chamber.
And when I said that Dr. like remained
in the echo chamber. I meant that he
turned down a discussion with somebody
who knows the right questions to ask and
is going to press him on those and
instead remained where he could be
comfortable with another Adventist
scholar and know that that's not going
to happen.
I'm aware that Christ Jesus Ministries
has had people like Jason Lyall on etc
who are not SDA. But as to character
attacks, I never attacked either of your
characters or claimed that he did so to
me. nor is that the agenda for tonight.
Nor has that been the root of my
arguments. What's funny about this
though is that the SDA church is on
record doing character assassination.
That's their standard MO. People like
Ford, Ratslife, Canrite daily.
That's not my MO as people are going to
see tonight.
But I actually had a decent amount of
respect for Dr. Lake prior to this,
which is why I was seeking to have a
good faith discussion with him. But that
is starting to change because he knows
me personally. We've had plenty of
cordial discussions before, not debates.
So why the cold feet all of a sudden if
it's recorded but then he continued,
it should be noted that this
presentation's only an introductory
overview of the issues. Ah, it's not an
attempt to re to refute specific
arguments in answering Adventism. Dr.
Dr. Lake will be providing more specific
responses to the issues Miles and others
have raised about Ellen White and
Adventism here and on other venues in
the days to come, such as his podcast,
the Ellen White podcast. This is not
only an engagement with Answering
Adventism, but with the issues
themselves. While faceoff debates may be
popular, Dr. Lake prefers to engage the
issues openly in non-confrontational
venues so listeners can hear the
arguments presented without
interruption. While others may be able
to devote full-time to this activity,
Dr. Lake is a full-time professor with
writing projects on top of responding to
the issues. Yeah, I'm aware I'm a former
student of his, Christopher.
So, responses will come to specific
issues, but according to Dr. Lake's
schedule, not that of anyone else.
Finally, I do hope that you view the
broadcast. Yeah, I did. Professor Lake
commended you for many things and took a
fair and objective approach to your
content. With that, I wish you a good
day.
Again, it's you guys that are mentioning
debate. Christopher, I never mentioned
that. Oh, sorry. I did to say not a
debate.
Where did I say in the in my comment or
the email that I wanted to have a
debate?
You guys saw it. I said a public-f
facing discussion in the comment, not a
debate. And I made it very apparent in
my email by restating the same thing. I
said again, it won't be this. I said I
was only going to ask questions. Let him
respond. Ask a question, let him
respond, etc. He would have full
unedited access to both video and audio.
But he said no because he didn't want to
debate, which I never solicited.
And then he said that the reason why was
because he already said all that he
needed to on the subject in his book yet
here you are telling us that you've got
lots of responses in Q.
Ah further evidencing that no he was
bluffing. He didn't say all that he
needed to on the subject and he was
willing to have a discussion but not on
record but he'll do it on record with
you.
Ah which is exactly my point. Echo
chamber. We all know the real reason,
folks. And I want you guys, Christopher,
Dr. Dr. Lake, any other Adventist
scholar. I want you to call my bluff.
See if I've done my homework, which is
the standard SDA objection. Oh, they
don't. It's exactly what's going on in
here, folks. Look at the tagline.
Identifying the mistakes of her critics.
No, Dr. Lake, you don't identify any
mistakes. You attack a bunch of straw
man. You just regurgitate and rehash a
bunch of FD nickel.
Call my bluff. Hopefully, we'll get that
in these future responses. But no, as
we're going to see tonight, Christopher,
he does not take an objective approach
to our content because I don't think
he's even consumed much of it based on
what he presents,
which again, people are going to see.
But Christopher, if this video I'm about
to respond to wasn't a response, which
is the other thing he said in that
comment,
it's only an introduction. Why'd you
title it SDA scholars respond to
answering Adventism?
Because the title of your guys's
response is, "Is the SDA church in
trouble? Adventist scholars respond to
critics answering Adventism."
Oh, no. It's not a response.
Dr. Lake already said all he needed to.
You can consider this my formal
response, part one, laying out the
objections that I look forward to you
guys addressing. Okay? Because to answer
the question in the title of your video,
yes, the SDA church is in a lot of
trouble. Big trouble. Straight to the
principal's office. We're calling Mama
Ellen who's at work and we're letting
her know that her kids are out of line,
which is what we're going to do tonight.
We're not just going to smack the hands.
We're going to send you home with a
demerit because it's not 1950 anymore.
It's a different era in the information
age. And on top of this, time is the
biggest enemy of the SDA movement. The
longer it goes on, the worse it becomes
for the SDA church. All Christ has to do
to put this enemy under his feet, this
false gospel in God, is let the clock
keep running.
But folks, if answering Adventism wasn't
having an impact, these people would be
ignoring us. But since the impact is
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
such that it's sending ripples through
the movement,
you guys can't ignore us anymore. So
instead, they're going to ignore me
personally and resort to responding from
a distance. In other words, we're right
over the target. They know it, I know
it, and they know that I know it.
They know that outside of the insulated
airconditioned halls of Adventist
academia, the system can't handle the
tough questions. Questions that those of
us who know the right ones to ask.
Questions from those of us that can see
through the word games and play them
right back.
So since the Scholastics want to stay in
their ivory tower, we have to resort to
having distant conversations via
response videos instead of a face tof
face interaction. And it's because of
your own representatives, Adventists,
not me. Understand this very clearly. I
went to bat for you guys. And your
teammate tagged me out. Now, like usual,
I want to start by laying some
groundwork before listening to their
response. First, I want us to look at
the answering adventism mission
statement. Okay?
It says, "Started by a third generation
former Seventh Day Adventist, we've
grown into a vibrant gospel-oriented
educational platform, clarifying the
divide between Adventism and historic
biblical Christianity. Our mission is to
demystify Adventism, unpacking its
doctrines, unraveling its history, and
underscoring its leadership through the
prism of biblical Christianity. We equip
Christians with knowledge and reach
Adventists with the true Christ in his
gospel, elevating his sovereign grace
and freedom to say, "For his own eternal
glory. To God alone be the glory." Very
straightforward.
We are an educational and apologetics
platform for Christians, not Seventh Day
Adventists.
We do not consider 7th Day Adventists
that affirm official SDA teaching to be
Christians.
But despite Christians being the
bullseye, there are a lot of Adventists
that learn from the content as well.
Praise God. We get lots of Adventists
who check out the material. We pres they
then look into the the sources for
themselves. They get redpilled and then
begin navigating through the deception.
But our bullseye to use marketing
jargon.
Adventists are a concentric circle
around the bullseye.
Both on target, one bullseye. Our goal
is to clarify the divide between where
Adventism deviates from Christian
orthodoxy, how the movement uses
Christian language, but means entirely
different things, etc. Which is why I'm
often focused not on every single
doctrinal difference possible. You can
scour our archives and find there's
certain topics I've never even not even
addressed. I've never even taken umbrage
with things that I don't even fault SDAs
for that I disagree with them on
because we have a mission with a focus.
We're typically focused here on
doctrinal universals that transcend just
my own Christian tradition.
And we do this by examining the SDA
church's doctrines, history, and
leadership by way of examining sermons,
official organizational publications,
the SDA pioneers, etc. Primary sources,
not individual SDAs
or or Joe Schmo SDA armchair theologian.
No, qualified organizational approved
sources.
Because ultimately our goal is to raise
the general consciousness of the
Christian church with regards to
Adventism, its theological dangers, and
showcase why we must be reaching them
with the truth. Equipping as many
Christians as possible to reach as many
Seventh Adventist possible with the true
Christ and his gospel, exalting God's
freedom to save for his own glory, which
is happening by the way. So the two
rings are connected but distant or
distinct rather. That's our mission. not
to preach. We're not a church. I'm not a
pastor.
We're engaging in pmics and apologetics
here. Yes, it's confrontational and
assertive. That's how pmics are by
nature. And Adventist PMIC organizations
are the exact same way.
But on this platform, we believe that
God saves people. And to be totally
transparent, there's not a single thing
the SDA church could do about it. So
Christopher, he erroneously claimed at
the beginning of their video that this
platform's goal is to get Adventists to
reconsider. And don't get me wrong, that
happens and praise God for it. But our
mission is to equip Christians and
defend the body of Christ from this
organization that slanders and labors
against the body of Christ and tries to
take the the the fake piety position
like Christopher did in that comment.
I knew full well before starting this
folks that nine out of 10 Adventists
will not change their mind. Christopher,
that is not my duty. That's God's
department. He works in the minds and
hearts of people to accomplish his
purposes. I don't know what God's
purposes are. That's parts of part of
God's secret will the the the secret
things of God that he hasn't chosen to
reveal. We simply want to be used by God
in the process because we care enough
about you all to state the truth boldly
and unashamedly, letting the chips fall
wherever they may. Okay. Point being,
the approach is tailored to Christians
unfamiliar with Adventism, not to SDAs.
And it seems like this misunderstanding
on his part informed the planning of
their video here. Makes me wonder if
either of them have actually read the
mission statement. Nevertheless, as it
pertains to their response, there are
three doctrinal aspects that they chose
to focus on.
great controversy, the salvation
experience, the gospel, and the gift of
prophecy. Three of their fundamental
beliefs.
These are the three areas they believe
that I've hammered the hardest and chose
to focus on. However, there is an
interconnectedness to all three, which
uh is also why I think they chose these.
But to adequately respond, I will do so
in three parts, one for each section.
And it sounds like we'll end up doing
multiple multiple multiple parts because
they want to keep putting stuff out and
they have stuff in Q. Fine. We'll play
that game too. But tonight's focus is
going to be on Jed Lake's presentation
of the great controversy. We will start
each part by steelmanning the SDA
position and the aspects that this
platform has objected to. That way it is
crystal clear. I will be reiterating
things that we've discussed many times
before to refresh your memory. Maybe
this is your first time with us. Either
way, let's set the stage. Okay.
When it comes to the great controversy,
I've regularly regularly noted that
there is a difference between the book,
the worldview, and the fundamental
belief. Though all three are
fundamentally connected,
it all comes downstream from Ellen White
forming the basis of the worldview, the
content of the book, and the summation
statement that is fundamental belief
number eight.
as it pertains to the great controversy
worldview or the theme.
I've argued it isn't biblical. It can't
be because it's not derived from
scripture. It comes from outside of
scripture and is the lens through which
the scriptures are then read, supposedly
giving an infallible interpretation.
Notice Herbert Douglas Ministry Magazine
December 2000. The link is in the
description for those that want to
follow along for themselves. This is a
forthright, honest, simple, and clear
presentation by arguably the SDA
church's foremost theologian to date.
Again, not Joe Schmo SDA, not conspiracy
church member off at the corner of the
potluck somewhere.
Quote, "For Seventh Day Adventists, the
great controversy theme is the core
concept that brings coherence to all
biblical subjects."
Every philosophical or theological
system builds on a central governing
theme or paradigm. Its central theme
becomes that system's core truth and
determines all of that systems
principles and policies.
Stephven Hawking, the remarkable
Cambridge physicist, wrote in his 1988
book, A Brief History of Time, that
should scientists discover the long
sought theory of everything to explain
the varying mechanisms of the universe,
we should know the mind of God.
Seventh Day Adventists have been given
that a perspective which provides a
theory of everything. It introduces us
to the mind of God. We didn't discover
it. It was given to us. We call it the
great controversy theme.
Did he say that?
Yes, Dr. O. He just said that. Thank you
for asking.
When they aren't playing word games
online and shoot you straight, they
admit that the great controversy
worldview was not derived from the
Bible.
It was given to them. Given. Folks, this
movement has an issue with this word
give and given, as we're going to see
later regarding this pre-earth origin
story that SDA's try to defend by
saying, "Well, no, that's that's not
what she meant by give." So maybe that's
the struggle here. But no, it's right
there. It was given to them. Supposedly
God God himself gave to the SDA church
by way of their prophetus who was a
conduit messenger that God would speak
through. It gives them access to the
mind of God.
Talk about a grand statement. You make
this claim, you bet you were going to be
skeptical and hyperritical. Who else is
making this claim? What an insane
statement. That's Herbert Douglas, Dr.
lake, not answering Adventism,
not some fringe fanatic off in the
corner somewhere in his ascension gown
because he heard the pope exhale, so he
knows when the second coming is going to
be all of a sudden. No, arguably the
foremost theologian your organization
has ever produced, a brilliant and
lauded light of the SDA movement. He
said, "The great controversy theme is
the core concept that brings coherence
to all biblical subjects.
All of Adventism is informed by this
paradigm. He continues,
"How we understand this core theme
directly affects how we grasp the intent
of the biblical writers when they used
words such as righteousness, salvation,
gospel, etc."
Remember, it doesn't come from
scripture, folks.
It defines gospel, righteousness, etc.
The great controversy theme helps us to
work our way through centuries of
theological confusion over the meaning
of such realities as justification,
sanctification, atonement, obedience,
and works.
Without the great controversy theme, all
would remain divided over such subjects
as the importance of the Old Testament
sanctuary service and the New Testament
view of Christ as our high priest
mediator, the meaning of faith and
grace, the place of obedience in
relation to legalism, why Jesus came the
first time and why he came the way he
did and when he will return.
Without the great controversy theme, all
would remain divided. It is the
theological antidote to any sort of
theological division. You've heard me
say that on this platform I don't know
how many times. There's not supposed to
be any division in this movement. You
have the God particle. It's supposed to
be what keeps there from being any
division from all those Babylonian
Protestants out there.
Every single doctrine is filtered
through this extra biblical paradigm.
It's what defines terms like gospel,
salvation, etc. And it supposedly helps
the SDA church work through all the
theological confusion that exists
outside their movement and allows
Adventism to be immune from that.
But notice the tail end. It informs why
Jesus came.
Why Jesus came the first time, which is
one of the central objections that I
have raised. what the SDA church claims
regarding why Jesus incarnated.
The claim that Jesus came to silence the
pre-earth accusations of Satan against
the character of God as a result of be
of Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the father. I have made this clear
on I don't know how many times
my challenge has then been that this
does not come from the Bible because it
doesn't.
Not a single Adventist in all of the
world will get on a stage with me before
a public audience and prove it because
it isn't there and they know it.
But Douglas continues,
"The Adventist esqueological framework
sets us apart from every other
denomination that speaks of the end of
the world because it is governed by the
great controversy theme.
The distinctly Adventist view is formed
by a mutually supportive cluster of
ideas." Ah, it's a system that you can't
cherrypick from because they're mutually
supportive clusters. They're in a
grouping together and they help help
bind one another together. You have to
have all of them. What are they?
Including conditional immortality,
seventh day sabotarianism, a
pre-millennial historicist esquetology.
Yeah, because you had their whole
understanding of Babylon is informed. Go
to our website, folks, and just type in
Charles Fitch in the search bar up top.
That's who that's why that's so central
to all this. This guy was a Millerite
preaching damnation on anyone who didn't
affirm premillennial historicism.
Conditional mortality, seventh day
sabotarianism, premillennial historicist
esquetology, acceptance of the gift of
prophecy in the ministry of Ellen White,
teachings about the priestly work of
Christ in the heavenly sanctuary, aka
investigative judgment in the sevenstep
sanctuary system, and a prepared people
by his grace, aka sinless perfectionism.
This mutually supportive cluster of
ideas that marks Adventist esquetology
exists today because the great
controversy theme informs all areas of
Adventist thought. That's the second
time he's told us this, folks. When the
great controversy is over, the purpose
of the gospel will be seen as the
vindication of the wisdom, power, and
love of God. Close quote.
Adventism is set apart from every other
denomination because it's governed by
the great controversy theme, not
scripture.
It's right there. Okay?
This worldview was given to them and it
governs everything in Adventism. It does
not get much clearer than that. Yet,
Adventists will still tell you, "I'm the
one twisting things. I'm the one that
doesn't know what I'm talking about,
apparently." No, you guys need to stop
saying you only believe the Bible.
You need to stop it. you're lying.
And I get so sick of them making these
false accusations
and false claims when they don't know
what the hell they're talking about. Get
out of the way and sit down.
That's the trajectory we're on tonight,
folks. I'm so sick of their lies. I'm so
sick of them demeaning people. I'm so
sick of them slandering people's
character. And I'm not talking about Jud
Lake and Christopher Saki, by the way.
I'm talking about the entity, the SDA
entity, the the the trade at 7th
Adventism trademark
that wants to lie about people and
slander people and tarnish people's
names. They've been doing this for 170
years. Not going to work anymore. Get
out of the way. Sit down if you don't
know what you're talking about.
The great controversy theme informs all
areas of Adventist theology. All
Adventists
class is in session and the teacher is
not in the greatest mood in in in terms
of the the the presentation here because
it needs to drive it home for you. All
all of Adventist theology, okay? So,
don't say answering Adventism is lying
when I say this. I'm so sick of SDA
saying that. No, I'm not lying.
We just read almost all of Herb
Douglas's article. Go look at it
yourself.
And when the great controversy between
Christ and Satan is over, the purpose of
the gospel will be seen, which is what?
The vindication of God.
So the other central thing that I've
taken umbrage with that God is on trial.
His character needs vindicated from
Satan, a creature. The Bible knows
nothing of this.
This is exceeding what is written. 1
Corinthians 4:6. Period.
Now, to put some skin on these bones,
let's look at a number of quotes from
Ellen White that fill in the details
that Herb Douglas's article, you know,
didn't get into.
So, the very beginning of this supposed
pre-earth controversy. Notice Spirit of
Prophecy, volume one,
the very beginning,
very first paragraph of this. Okay? And
we're going to walk through this.
Sorry folks, it's going to be a long
night and I'm I'm about
uh my give a damn broke a long time ago
with the SDA church. Quote, "Satan in
heaven before his rebellion was a high
and exalted angel next in honor to God's
dear son.
His countenance, like those of the other
angels, was mild and expressive of
happiness. His forehead was high and
broad, showing a powerful intellect. His
form was perfect, his bearing noble and
majestic. A special light beamed in his
countenance and shone around him
brighter and more beautiful than around
the other angels. Yet Jesus, God's dear
son, had the preeminence over all the
angelic host. He was one with the father
before the angels were created. Satan
was envious of Christ and gradually
assumed command which
devolved
on Christ alone. close quote.
So Lucifer was supposedly next in honor
to Jesus Christ who is Yahweh according
to the Bible. The Almighty
Ellen has Jesus eternally subordinate
which poses serious problems in and of
itself.
Satan also doesn't have a brow ridge.
Angels are not human beings with wings.
None of that is in scripture. Satan does
not have a brow.
Nevertheless, she said that Satan was
envious of Jesus Christ and did what?
That last sentence that's highlighted,
started to assume command which devolved
onto Christ. What does the word devolved
mean, folks?
It is where a higher authority transfers
power to a lower authority,
which is precisely what she goes on to
explain.
So
to this woman
of our friend Steve Dailyaly
now adventists are going to try and tell
you no no no look she's she says Jesus
was one with the father. Yeah we've
looked at what that means and what she
meant by that. It doesn't mean that
Jesus was eternally co-equal.
It means they were eternally united in a
mission. They've never been at any sort
of cross purposes because notice
quote the great creator assembled the
heavenly host that he might in the
presence of all the angels confer
special honor upon his son.
The son was seated on the throne with
the father and the heavenly thr of holy
angels was gathered around them. The
father then made known that it was
ordained by himself that Christ his son
should be equal with himself.
So that wherever was the presence of his
son, it was as his own presence.
The word of the son was to be obeyed as
readily as the word of the father.
Remember command devolved onto Christ.
And now that this announcement is being
made, it's as if whenever Jesus gives a
command, it's now supposed to be like
the father's giving the command.
His son he had invested
with authority to command the heavenly
host
especially was his son to work in union
with himself in the anticipation or
anticipated creation of the earth and
every living thing that should exist
upon the earth.
His son would carry out his will and his
purposes but would do nothing of himself
alone. The father's will would be
fulfilled in him. Close quote. So the
father devolved authority to the son
that he didn't previously possess and
made known that he was to be obeyed as
if it were the father himself giving the
commands. The son now shared in the same
authority. The son was invested with
authority.
Does invest mean always possessed?
No. It means put into or given. Don't
try and tell us she wasn't saying that
Jesus wasn't a lesser divine being than
the father.
And I get so tired of Adventists trying
to insult our intelligence by saying we
can't read and compreh comprehend a
third grade educated woman from the 19th
century. No, my IQ is above room
temperature. So stop trying to tell us
that we don't have basic reading
comprehension. I I mean folks, it's very
obvious. And she says it and I don't how
many ways. Jesus was given authority he
didn't possess. He isn't Yahweh, the
eternal God. Jesus is the same
yesterday, today, and forever. Hebrews
13:8. This is speaking specifically
about his immutability of nature being
in character.
Jesus has always been and always will be
the almighty God, one with the father
and the spirit. Not just in omission,
but in attribution and substance.
They can cling to saying they believe
Jesus is eternal, but that doesn't mean
he's the almighty God. That's their big
thing. Like Ted Wilson's been doing this
recently. We believe the Son is eternal
with the father. That doesn't mean
anything. So do tritheus. Tritheus
believe that doesn't mean you're a
trinitarian. He's been saying all this
in response to these old school SDAs
that are in line with the pioneers that
that say, "Well, no, Jesus had a
beginning at some point in the past."
And they think, "Oh, if we deny that,
that means that we're trinit." No, you
guys don't believe in the true biblical
Christ.
But no, the Jesus in this system is not
Yahweh.
only the father is. The pioneers taught
that and the official SDA source
materials still teach that to this day.
They have to because this is the
foundation for their entire worldview
that Herb Douglas just got done telling
us is the theological God particle and
allows them to be immune from
theological confusion and division and
really know what's going on behind the
scenes in heaven.
So no, Jesus wasn't eternally equal with
the father. Jesus is a lesser distinct
being from the father. And this action
was what?
It was done in the anticipation of the
creation of the earth. We had an
Adventist this past week tell us that
I'm lying when I say that the SDA church
teaches there was a massive expanse of
time between the creation of the of
heaven and the angels and the earth. He
claimed he'd never heard anywhere in
Adventism where this is taught. And if I
could prove this, he would agree the SDA
church is wrong and leave. I mean, are
you kidding me? Is that a joke? This is
literally central to the entire
framework of SDA theology, my guy.
Have you cracked open these books? You
even read this the very beginning. We're
two paragraphs in.
It's literally in the second paragraph
in the soon anticipation of the creation
of the earth. That's not Genesis 1:1.
And it should concern you that this is
central to SDA theology and you're not
even keyed in on it. Yet you're a part
of a movement that's catechizing you in
this worldview.
You're being spiritually poisoned and
can't even see it. It's time to leave
Adventism, my friend. But then she
explains what this led to in heaven.
Supposedly,
Satan was envious and jealous of Jesus
Christ.
Yet when all the angels bowed to Jesus
to acknowledge his supremacy and high
authority and rightful rule, Satan bowed
with them, but his heart was filled with
envy and hatred.
Christ had been taken into the special
counsel of God in regarding to in regard
to his plans while Satan was
unacquainted with them. He did not
understand, neither was he permitted to
know the purposes of God. But Christ was
acknowledged sovereign of heaven, his
power and authority to be the same as
that of God himself.
Satan thought that he was himself a
favorite in heaven among the angels.
Close quote. So Satan was or Lucifer at
this time was jealous of this exaltation
and authority that was given to Jesus
and started to think why wasn't I the
one that was exalted. Why wasn't I given
the power?
And again like I said earlier just as an
aside the word the pre-incarnate Christ
did not assume the name Jesus until the
incarnation.
What Ellen puts forth in this narrative
is what's called eternal subordination
of the son or ESS
that there is a hierarchy within the
godhead and the father's at the top with
the word being eternally subordinate in
role obeying the father in eternity.
It is a heresy and I'd be glad to debate
that with any SDA theologian or scholar
on this.
But all that to say uh uh add eternal
functional subordination to the SDA
heresy bucket.
She continues,
"He had been highly exalted," talking
about Satan, Lucifer, but this did not
call forth from him gratitude and praise
to his creator. He aspired to the height
of God himself. He gloried in his
loftiness. He knew that he was honored
by the angels. He had a special mission
to execute. He had been near the great
creator and the ceaseless beams of
glorious light in shrouding the eternal
God had shown especially around him.
Satan thought how angels had obeyed his
command with pleasurable elacrity. Were
not his garments light and beautiful?
Why should Christ thus be honored before
himself? Close quote. So Lucifer was
also highly exalted just not like Jesus
who was made equal with the father.
This exaltation of Jesus made Lucifer
jealous. And this is the trigger of the
great controversy.
Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the father leads to Lucifer welling
up with pride. They will point to
scriptures that say Satan was filled
with pride and wanted to be like God and
think and think that somehow supports
this narrative. No, it doesn't. Because
scripture doesn't say Lucifer became
jealous because Jesus was exalted and
Lucifer wanted to be like Jesus who was
made equal with God. That is whole cloth
coming from Ellen White.
She goes on to say the loyal angels in
heaven sought to counsel Lucifer to
repent and give Jesus the honor that he
was due, but he just wouldn't listen.
But then this leads to Satan making
accusations. Notice
quote, "The loyal angels hasten speedily
to the son of God and acquaint with him
uh with what is taking place among the
angels. They find the father in
conference with his beloved son to
determine the means by which for the
best good of the loyal angels, the
assumed authority of Satan could be
forever put down. The great God could at
once have hurled this arch deceiver from
heaven, but this was not his purpose.
He would give the rebellious an equal
chance to measure strength and might
with his own son and his loyal angels.
In this battle, every angel would choose
his own side and be manifested to all.
Holy Toledo, this woman.
So angels went to relay to Jesus what
was going on with Satan. That they tried
talking him down off the edge, but he
was too far gone. And when the angels
went to do this, they found that Jesus
was in a council meeting with the father
to determine the solution to this
rebellion. The father could have just
hurled Lucifer down, but instead chose
to allow it to play out and give every
angel a chance to make their decision.
Remain loyal to his government or side
with Satan in his plan of
self-governance.
God the Father gave the rebellious an
equal chance to measure strength and
might with Jesus the son. Such a joke.
There's there's no cosmic arm wrestling
going on between Christ and Satan. This
is how the narrative props up Satan, by
the way, to be the tragic hero of this
whole fantasy. Now, if you're a
Christian, you're more than likely
thinking, "Where did I miss this in in
the Bible?" Uh, it's more than likely
because your Bible doesn't contain first
and second fiction like the SDA Bible
does. But she continues,
"Whoops, I forgot a quote here.
She says, "It would not have been safe
to suffer any who united with Satan in
his rebellion to continue to occupy
heaven. They had learned the lesson of
genuine rebellion against the
unchangeable law of God. And this is
incurable."
If God had exercised his power to punish
this chief rebel, disaffected angels
would not have been manifested. Hence,
God took another course, for he would
manifest distinctly to all the heavenly
host his justice and his judgment.
So, the father didn't blot Satan out of
existence because it would have
demonstrated Satan's accusations were
true. God's a tyrant. And then they'll
say, "And this would have communicated
to the disloyal angels that Satan was
correct, leading to the angels serving
God out of fear instead of love." So
instead, Jesus and the father decided to
let this great controversy play out to
vindicate the justice and government of
God. This is science fiction, folks.
None of this is in the Bible.
I understand Adventists think it gives
them some special insight into heaven
that no one else has. But no, this is a
ripoff of the Mormon plan of salvation,
which is clearly a ripoff of John
Milton's Paradise Lost.
But there you have the heart of this.
So, Satan's rebellion led to a council
meeting between Jesus and the Father to
figure out a plan for all this. But the
SDA church is trinitarian, they'll tell
you. Yeah. Think again.
Now, notice what she says.
The accusation was
Christ left his position in the heavenly
courts and came to this earth to live
the life of human beings. This
sacrifice, the incarnation, he made in
order to show that Satan's charge
against God is false. That it's possible
for man to obey the laws of God's
kingdom. Close quote.
So there you have it, plainly stated.
Satan began attacking the Ten
Commandments, saying they can't be kept.
And as Herb Douglas admitted, the great
controversy theme informs all areas of
SDA thought and theology, including why
Jesus came.
So why did he incarnate according to
Adventism?
To silence these accusations from Satan?
No. You will not find this anywhere in
the Bible. Nowhere. which is the central
objection that I have made and ask their
scholars and theologians to show me for
years. Still waiting.
But she says, "If God the Father would
have banished Satan after this
rebellion, it would have reinforced
Satan's accusations that God's a tyrant
and it would have proved Satan's point."
So Jesus and the Father came up with a
plan that would allow each angel to pick
their side. This is the start of the
great controversy that then leads to war
in heaven, which they're then going to
cite Revelation 12, which all it says is
war broke out in heaven,
even though it literally says none of
this other stuff. They'll just hitch
their wagon to that. But this war then
led to the banishment and Satan was cast
down to the earth after the father and
the son created it. He then tempts man.
Man falls. And after that happens, she
then says this,
"Sorrow filled heaven as it was realized
that man was lost and the world that God
created was to be filled with mortals
doomed to misery, sickness, and death,
and there was no way of escape for the
offender. The whole family of Adam must
die. I saw the lovely Jesus and beheld
an expression of sympathy and sorrow
upon his countenance." Soon I saw him
approach the exceeding bright light
which enshrouded the father, said my
accompanying angel. He's in close
converse with his father. The anxiety of
the angels seemed to be intense while
Jesus was communing with his father.
Three times he was shut in by the
glorious light about the father. And the
third time he came from the father, his
person could be seen. So the father was
too glorious to behold but not Christ.
Again the demoting of the word the
second person of the godhead.
His countenance was calm, free from all
perplexity and trouble, and shown with
benevolence and loveliness, such as
words cannot express. He then made known
to the angelic host that a way of escape
had been made for lost man. He told them
that he'd been pleading with his father
and had offered to give his life a
ransom and take the sentence of death
upon himself that through him man might
find pardon that through the merits of
his blood and obedience to the law of
God they could have the favor of God and
be brought into the beautiful garden to
eat of the fruit of the tree of life.
Close quote. So the great controversy
then supposedly spread to the earth and
man is now involved. You pick your side
in this controversy by siding with
either Jesus and his angels or Satan and
his angels. Notice in heavenly places
page 38.
So deep was the Lord's interest in the
beings that he create uh beings he had
created. So great his love for the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life. Christ
came to bring moral power to man to
elevate and noble and and strengthen him
enabling him to be a partaker of the
divine nature. Having escaped the
corruption that is in the world through
lust, he proved to the inhabitants of
the unfallen worlds and to human beings
the law can be kept. While possessing
the nature of man, he obeyed the law of
God, vindicating God's justice in
demanding that it be obeyed. In the
judgment, his life will be an
unanswerable argument in favor of God's
law. Close quote.
You make your pick in the great
controversy by coming to Jesus who will
forgive you of your violations of the
law up to that point. Then it will
enable you to now keep the law by
gradually imparting his righteous merits
to you. And eventually you too can keep
the law as perfectly as Jesus when the
character of of Christ is perfectly
mirrored in you. what they believe is
returning to being made in the image of
God, which then silences Satan in the
great controversy and vindicates God
because Jesus took on an identical
fallen nature like all of humanity and
he kept the law perfectly. So you too
can do that and vindicate God in the
great controversy. Because another
aspect of all of this is all these other
beings on other worlds that supposedly
all watching on the earth like a TV
screen, like a stage.
They're also keeping the Ten
Commandments and have questions
regarding God's character, Ellen said.
So God's vindicating himself to them as
well. And you too can by linking up with
Jesus who will empower you to keep the
law so these other beings can see, okay,
we can trust God. We can believe God
even though they're supposedly keeping
the law.
They haven't fallen. They're keeping the
law perfectly, but still apparently have
doubts about God and his character and
are watching in this great controversy
as God vindicates himself.
But ultimately, all of this goes back to
the top of the stream. Jesus was exalted
to be made equal with the father.
Lucifer became jealous. And now there's
a great controversy over this and God
has to vindicate his character. None of
this is in the Bible, nor does it come
from the Bible. It comes from Ellen
White, who the SDA church thinks is no
different than scripture when it comes
to God's revelation.
Now, since Adventists will claim things
like, "I don't read Ellen White. My
pastor never mentions Ellen White in
these sorts of excuses," the same thing
is reiterated in their Adventist belief,
fundamental beliefs book. Okay,
notice
first paragraph of the chapter on the
fundamental belief number eight, the
great controversy, page 113.
Scripture portrays a cosmic battle
between good and evil, God and Satan.
Understanding this controversy which has
involved the entire universe helps
answer the question,
why did Jesus come to this planet?
So for all the Adventists that want to
act like what Herb Douglas said is some
obscure private opinion of his, no, this
is the same thing that's reiterated in
the exposition of the beliefs because
they continue and will reiterate what
Ellen White is saying. Notice
what is the pivotal issue in this life
and death struggle? God's government and
law, which is the heading for what for
the section that it then goes into.
God's moral law is just as essential to
the existence of his universe as are the
physical laws that hold it together and
keep it functioning. Sin is
transgression of the law. 1 John 3:4. It
is lawlessness as the Greek word anomia
indicates. Lawlessness in issues from a
rejection of God and his government.
Rather than admitting responsibility for
the lawlessness of the world, Satan lays
the blame on God. He says God's law,
which he alleges is arbitrary, infringes
on individual freedom.
Furthermore, he charges since it's
impossible to obey it, the law works
against the best interest of created
beings.
Through this constant and insidious
undermining of the law, Satan attempts
to overthrow God's government and even
God himself. Close quote. Folks, the
Bible nowhere says this, and they didn't
even bother to try and provide even an
outof context proof text to try and
support it. This is whole cloth Ellen
White. They continue by saying, "Today,
the great controversy raging furiously
around Christ's authority
involves not only his law, but his word,
the scriptures."
What did we read from Ellen White
regarding this authority? It devolved
onto Jesus from the father. He was made
equal with the father. We've looked at
testimonies for the church volume 8. I
don't know how many times. Christ it uh
god is the father of Christ. Christ is
the son of God. To Christ has been
given.
He has been made equal with the father.
She's saying this over and over and over
again.
Devolved means a greater authority
bestows authority onto a lower
individual, Jesus, which triggered
Lucifer's rebellion. So even the
fundamental beliefs book tries to ignore
this glaring detail, yet still works it
in there. But it also shows the
doctrinal development that's happened
regarding the SDA church despite having
the great controversy theme. Because if
you recall from the burial service of
the SDA pioneers, James White said that
the law was exclusively the father's law
which God gave the stamp of approval on
supposedly through Ellen White volume
two of the same book that we were just
in.
quote, "The son of God was next in
authority,
next in authority to the great
lawgiver."
The lawgiver is the father.
He knew that his life alone could be
sufficient to ransom fallen man. He was
of as much more value than man as his
noble, spotless character, and exalted
office as commander of all the heavenly
host were above the work of man. He was
in the express image of his father, not
in features alone, but in perfection of
character. Close quote.
If Jesus is next in authority to the
great lawgiver, it means he isn't the
great lawgiver
and doesn't have as much authority as
the great lawgiver, aka God the Father,
which further demonstrates that Jesus,
according to the SDA church's inspired
prophetus, is a lesser divine being than
God the Father, who is the eternal God.
But then later, it evolves. And no, no,
no, it's just as much Jesus's law, too.
Hence why the beliefs book says what it
does. But I digress. They continue in
the beliefs book under the heading,
it reveals the cosmic significance on
the cross, speaking about the great
controversy. Quote, "The salvation of
humanity was at stake in Christ's
ministry and death. For he came to give
his life a ransom for the remission of
sins. In doing so,
he vindicated his father's character,
law, and government against which Satan
had cast false aspersions.
Yeah. Book, chapter, verse. SDA church.
All right. You didn't include any
again. More science fiction.
Because this isn't what the Bible
teaches.
The Bible nowhere teaches that Jesus
came to silence a creature who made
accusations against the Ten Commandments
and God's character prior to the earth
being created because he was jealous
that Jesus was exalted instead of
himself. and that Jesus vindicated God
the Father's character against Satan by
incarnating and demonstrating that the
law can be kept perfectly
which is actually another contradiction
by the way because it wouldn't be the
father's character. It would be both
Jesus and the father because Ellen
claimed Jesus is an identical reflection
of the father's character.
But this is why the law is so central in
Adventism, folks. And it can't possibly
be that but that they don't actually
understand the subject as well as they
think they do. It's why anyone that
disagrees with them is said to be a tool
of Satan that's an Antonyomian and is
lawless and is just and that they're
siding with Satan in this imaginary, you
know, fictional galactic battle.
All of this extra biblical confusion is
brought to the text and it's assumed to
be what the Bible's talking about, but
isn't exhaustive
because the Bible supposedly doesn't
have all these other details. But we'll
see over here it says war broke out in
heaven. Oh, so you can just hit your
wagon of all these extra details now and
that just makes it relevant because
there was war in heaven.
No, that's why they they they think you
need the writings of Ellen where Jesus
is supposedly speaking to connect the
dots and give you the infallible
interpretation and understanding of the
Bible. Now, I could keep going,
but this has laid out using my own using
their own sources what my objections
have been. To summarize,
these are my formal objections on this
subject. There are more, but these are
the four primary objectives or are
objections.
One, Jesus was not exalted to be made
equal with the father. This is damnable
heresy.
Two, Lucifer was never next to Christ,
who is Yahweh the Almighty.
Three, God is not and does not need to
vindicate his character. And four, Jesus
did not incarnate to silence pre-earth
accusations from Satan,
which was then done to exalt the law and
silence Satan and demonstrate that
fallen man can also do the same, yada
yada.
None of this is biblical. None of this
can be supported from the Bible, which
is why they don't even try in their
fundamental beliefs book. And yet, it's
all foundational to Adventist theology.
You eliminate this stuff, the whole SDA
framework collapses.
The great controversy theme is not
biblical. It didn't come from reading
scripture. It was it was supposedly
uniquely given to the SDA church. It's
the antidote to theological division and
brings total cohesion to all of the
Bible.
Those have been my central objections on
this subject, whether it be the book,
the fundamental belief, the worldview,
which are all connected.
So, Dr. Lake, was Herb Douglas lying in
Ministry magazine?
Is he unqualified?
Am I just picking on Joe Schmo? No. Do
we need someone to handhold us to
understand the very plain,
straightforward admission that fits like
a glove with Ellen White's own claims?
thesis for tonight.
With all that said,
do these SDA scholars address Answering
Adventism's objections regarding the
great controversy?
Do Dr. Lake and Christopher Sernaki
address Answering Adventism's objections
regarding the great controversy?
As you saw from his comment earlier, oh,
this wasn't a response. Well, you titled
it a response, buddy.
But that's what we're going to be
looking for. All right. Are these
objections addressed and demonstrated
from scripture? If they aren't addressed
and demonstrated, our objections remain
valid and the issues still stand. And
yes, the SDA church is in big trouble
because we're not slowing down. We're
not stopping. We are storming the gates
of hell, smashing them down with the
truth, and more and more Adventists will
be reached. God will save his people.
Adventism will be made a foottool
underneath the feet of Christ and
there's nothing the SDA church can do
about it. So with that said, let's
listen to the first section or rather
the first section was was Judg basically
giving his testimony. Then they transfer
to the objections. So that's where we're
going to start again. Great controversy
objections.
Here we go.
I'm going to begin this second section
by directly reading the eighth
fundamental belief which reads as
follows.
All humanity is now involved in a great
controversy between Christ and Satan
regarding the character of God, his law,
and his sovereignty over the universe.
This conflict originated in heaven when
a created being endowed with freedom of
choice in self-exaltation
became Satan, God's adversary, and led
into rebellion a portion of the angels.
He introduced the spirit of rebellion
into this world when he led Adam and Eve
into sin. This human sin resulted in the
distortion of the image of God in
humanity. The disordering of the created
world and its eventual devastation at
the time of the global flood as
presented in the historical account of
Genesis 1-11.
Observed by the whole creation, this
world became the arena of the universal
conflict out of which the God of love
will ultimately be vindicated. to assist
his people in this controversy. Christ
sends the Holy Spirit and the loyal
angels to guide, protect, and sustain
them in the way of salvation. So, Dr.
Lake, we just finished reading the
eighth fundamental belief. Does the
Bible teach this concept of a great
controversy or cosmic conflict? Or is
this a teaching exclusive to the
writings of Ellen White? That is the key
question. And I think just a surface
level reading of the Bible, one can
discern there is an epic
battle between good and evil. I mean
that's just basic Bible 101.
You read about this adversary in the
scriptures and that adversary is against
Christ. that adversary deceived God's
people in the Old Testament and he
attempts to destroy Christ and his
people in the New Testament. At the very
outset of the Bible, this controversy,
this what I like to call this cosmic
conflict is set forth. God creates
everything perfect and then in Genesis
3, you have suddenly this serpent come
on the scene, this crafty serpent. And
that serpent has evil intentions. And as
you read the narrative, the serpent
causes Adam and Eve to disobey God and
plunge the human race into sin. It's as
if Moses presupposes that his readers
understand that there's more to the
story than this. There's a story behind
that serpent. And when you read the rest
of scripture, the pieces of the puzzle
come together.
So, is the great controversy in the
Bible or exclusive to Ellen White? Yes,
that is the key question indeed. But Dr.
Lake, all you did was caricature the
belief by trying to make it seem like
it's almost unbelievable to even reject
such a concept because it's just so
plainly in scripture.
These gentlemen bring their great
controversy worldview to the Bible,
which clouds their thinking and reading
of the Bible, causing them to think this
is all over the Bible.
But no, it isn't. Which is why
Christians don't have a great
controversy worldview.
It's the root of what puts Adventism
outside of Christianity in its own
category. The scriptures have a
worldview and it's not the great
controversy.
He made it seem like all the great
controversy is is simply the belief that
there's a Satan who's an adversary, that
there's good and evil. They always do
this. But he didn't demonstrate all the
actual details that are necessary in the
system for it to work. Namely, the
objections that I raised. So with a
surface level reading of the Bible, we
should see that prior to the creation of
the earth, Jesus was exalted to be made
equal with the father. This made Lucifer
jealous and he started a great
controversy over Jesus's authority in
the Ten Commandments.
Why didn't you share any plain
scriptures, Dr. Lake?
Those have been my objections, not this
generalized, watered down idea that
there's a Satan.
If this were plainly in the Bible, you
guys would have demonstrated such and
silenced my accusations like you guys
think you're doing to Satan. Instead, he
just regurgitated claims made in the eth
chapter of the Adventist belief
fundamental belie that we just looked
at. But even that provided zero evidence
for the objections this platform has
raised.
And they love to appeal to the barebones
language of the fundamental belief to
act like it doesn't go any further than
that. That's as far as it goes. Except
no, it goes much farther than that.
which is why they have the exposition of
the beliefs like we looked at and even
that leaves out certain details from
Ellen that they know are problematic.
The book just asserts these extra
biblical details as facts and moves
along sprinkling in a number of out of
context proof texts such as Jesus being
tempted in the wilderness. Something
that Dr. Lakes is going to appeal to
here in a moment. But what did page 116
of the police book talk about? Satan's
pre-earth accusations,
which is what I've actually objected to.
He's ignored that so far. Tried watering
it down with the sort of, "Oh, the great
controversy is just there's a Satan
that's an enemy of God. It's just
obvious."
As we plainly saw, Herb Douglas said,
"This worldview, which includes this
entire belief system, was given to the
SDA church." No, it doesn't come from
the Bible, Christopher. It was uniquely
given to the SDA church and it's
supposedly what allows you all to make
sense of the Bible as a whole and avoid
doctrinal confusion like us confused
Protestants. And I think Herb Douglas is
more qualified than you, sir. No
offense. I think Ministry Magazine has
more authority than you, sir.
It can't come from scripture if it's
necessary to have in order to understand
scripture. I keep hammering on this. I
can't tell you how many SDAs say they've
been redpilled on this and realize, "Oh,
wow. Yeah, it's not. It's not just the
Bible, folks. None of this is in the
Bible. You're just bringing this to the
text and it's just, oh, it's so obvious.
Look over here. There's this." And
you're going to see him do that. You're
going to see him do that.
You guys can point to general statements
in scripture like Dr. Lake tries to do,
but none of that validates the belief.
That's just playing the doctrine in
search of a text game. It's called
isoges Jesus. You're just bringing
something to the text and then looking
for somewhere that you can go, "Aha,"
and then plug it in. Find a verse that
speaks of a thematic aspect of the
belief such as there being war in
heaven, which then supposedly validates
reading into all these statements of
extra biblical details that are not
found in the Bible. It's not adding to
the Bible, they'll say, because Ellen
jives with the general statement,
which proves that despite the SDA church
being against competitive sport, if
mental gymnastics were an Olympic sport,
the SDA church would take home the gold.
He mentioned Genesis 3 that Moses
presupposes that the readers understand
there's more to the story than this.
There's a story behind the serpent.
But then he said the rest of the story
is laid out in scripture. No, Dr. Lake,
that's where you're wrong. No, it isn't.
No, it isn't.
It's in Ellen White's writings. It comes
from the great controversy paradigm that
Dr. Douglas admitted was given to you
all to then interpret the scriptures
through,
you have it backwards, sir. If this
backstory to the serpent that you you
say Moses assumes his readers will know,
then why did it take nearly 5,000 years
from Moses for humanity to receive all
this extra biblical information through
your prophetus?
If this backstory is laid out all
throughout the rest of scripture after
Genesis, then why didn't we hear any
support for this backstory?
The pieces of the puzzle that you guys
need are not found in the Bible. You
guys are going to get tired of hearing
me say that tonight. I'm going to keep
saying it in hopes that there's some
poor SDA soul out there that maybe the
thousand1th time thousand thousand and
burst, you get my point. It'll click and
they'll go, "Oh, right. It's not in the
Bible. Get the hell out of here. Get
leave Adventism. Get out of here. Go
where the Bible leads. And it doesn't
lead there.
You need all these details, Dr. Lake,
for this whole thing to function. You
know, the actual things I've objected to
as being not just unbiblical, but
anti-biblical. They create
contradictions with scripture and result
in damnable heresy in the form of a
false god and a false gospel.
So far, this addresses none of the
objections we've raised. I know it's
been short, but nowhere have I ever
stated that the idea of there being a
Satan is unique to the writings of Ellen
White.
So, when you do your real responses or
whatever you have planned, Christopher,
you guys are going to need to bring a
lot more than this. But the key verse, I
think, foundational to scripture is
Genesis 3:15. After Adam and Eve have
fallen into sin, you have God comes and
it's like a a investigative type of
judgment scene. God calls for Adam and
Eve, where are you? And then they
acknowledge the sin, their sin, and then
you have God pronouncing the sentence.
And if you study Genesis 3 carefully,
it's it's written in what is called a
kayastic structure that builds to a
literary center, an apex. And the center
of that chapter, the literary center
which is the most important part is
Genesis 3:14 and 15 where God speaks
directly to the serpent. Verse 14, he
curses the serpent. Later in scripture,
we know that the force behind that
serpent. The person behind that serpent
is Satan, the great adversary. He is
cursed. But Genesis
3:15, right at the heart of the chapter,
is the promise of a savior. A savior.
It's called a first gospel,
pro-evangelium,
a first gospel in the scripture because
it promises the coming of a redeemer. It
is a messianic promise. The he at the
deepest level of the verse, the he is
against
the serpent. In fact, the text reads,
"He shall bruise your head." Speaking to
the serpent, "and you shall bruise his
heel." That he is a personal masculine
pronoun. That is the promise of a
redeemer. And you read the rest of
Genesis. It flows out of this verse. But
what is
important is the word that begins the
whole verse which actually the sentence
begins with the Hebrew word for enmity
which means intense hostility.
Now we won't be able to unpack this
whole verse completely but that intense
hostility reaches its deepest level
between the he and the serpent. Moses
traces those two seeds the seed of the
serpent and the seed of the woman. the
Messiah would come through the seed of
the woman. Those two are at odds against
one another throughout the rest of the
book of Genesis. You see that follow
throughout the Old Testament and into
the New Testament when the seed of the
woman finds its fullest expression at
the birth of Jesus Christ, beginning
with the Gospel of Matthew. But as we
look over the Old Testament, you have
numerous places that refer to this
conflict. Job 1:es 6-12 when Satan comes
before this celestial meeting of beings
before God. Uh you see the the cosmic
conflict work itself out in the
experience of Job and suffering and
where the curtain is pulled back and we
can see what is taking place. You've got
Isaiah 14:12 and 14, Ezekiel 28:12-18.
We won't be able to unpack those in
detail right now, but while they're
talking about earthly kings, the
language in the Hebrew shifts in a very
careful way to something beyond a human
power, which indicates a a supernatural
power of evil. And so those two passages
in Isaiah 14 and Ezekiel 28 uh there
have been doctrinal dissertations
written about those those verses and
indicating that this is clearly a
reference to Lucifer's
self-exaltation in heaven. But the real
apex of the conflict in scripture occurs
in the four gospels with namely the
synoptic gospels Matthew, Mark and Luke
with the temptations where Jesus and
Satan face one another one another eye
to eye toeto toe locked in conflict. You
clearly see the cosmic conflict taking
place right there. It's clear that the
battlefield of this conflict is planet
earth. That's quite clear from
scripture. This is something that
several evangelical scholars have
acknowledged and recognized.
Now, Dr. Lake, Dr. Lake, come on.
You're caricaturing the belief and you
know this.
That's why it's hard to take you guys
seriously sometimes on this subject,
man. Like, it it like it takes me back
to to being your student, man. I feel
like the same thing would always happen.
It's like Dr. Lake, you're dancing
around. You're dancing around. I like
you, sir. You know this, you're a nice
guy. He's a nice guy, folks. He's a
really nice guy, actually.
But doctor, like, you're you're
caricaturing the belief and you're
stretching here. You're stretching here.
But it's hard to take you guys seriously
when you do this. It's like playing the
there he is game with my 2-year-old. He
pulls the shirt over his head and he
thinks we can't see him, but then he
quickly lowers it down and says, "There
he is." And we play along with him. You
guys are like the toddler that's pulling
the shirt over your eyes, thinking we
can't very clearly see the elephant in
the room because you guys have pulled
the theological shirt over your eyes.
Notice he said Genesis 3:15 is like an
investigative judgment type scene.
They love working in SDA vernacular
anywhere they can. But he says Genesis
3:15 the uh the protoangelion.
Dr. Like that has nothing to do with the
great controversy. Nothing. Because the
great controversy isn't this boiled down
belief that there's simply a devil and
then a Jesus that crushes him,
which is what you're trying to position
it as. And in my opinion is dishonest
because Dr. Lake, why didn't you address
why Jesus came?
Why did Jesus come?
Does it say that in in in Genesis 3:15
or anywhere in the Bible for that? You
said it lays this whole thing out all
the way through scripture. Again,
avoiding the actual objections that I've
raised,
where is this platform claim that
Genesis 3:15 isn't the first
proclamation of the gospel? I've pointed
this out numerous times. What I've taken
umbrage with regarding Genesis 3:15 and
Adventism is why Jesus came, which Herb
Douglas told us is defined in light of
the great controversy theme, not
scripture.
The claim being like even the
fundamental beliefs book says and even
the belief itself that Christopher read
was that he came to silence accusations
from Satan. You ignored this
pointing to places like Job 1, Isaiah
14, Ezekiel 28. That doesn't prove these
extra details that form the entire
structure of the great controversy
paradigm.
Those are simply places that show Satan
as an adversary.
And even if you did have time to unpack
them, it wouldn't matter because they
don't teach and say what you need them
to in order to actually silence my
accusations against SDA theology proper.
We got a lot of rabbit trailing there on
things I've never objected to. Folks,
this is supposed to be a response to
answering Adventism. And Christopher, I
know that you said in your comment back
to me, well, this wasn't really a
response. Well, then why'd you title the
video that it's a response?
And for those who have been writing with
us for quite some time, I know you all
can see this. Jud is just preaching
here. He's not responding.
Bringing things up like the literary
structure of Genesis, its kayastic
structure, etc. These are all red
herrings.
No, Dr. Lake. Proving that the king of
Ty is a picture of Lucifer doesn't prove
that prior to the creation of earth,
Lucifer was jealous that Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with the
father, which led to him accusing the
god in the ten commandments. So Jesus
came to silence those accusations and
thus Genesis 3:15 proves the great
controversy.
Lucifer wanting to exalt himself in
heaven doesn't prove this fictional
storyline that you guys bring to the
narrative that then drives things such
as why Jesus incarnated. Sir,
this was a lot of scholastic bloation
for people who aren't aware of the
actual objections who will see this and
think, "Wow, Dr. Lake really showed
answering Adventism. he used fancy words
like kayastic structure and
protoangelion.
They'll then start going around and
telling Adventists that scholars have
already dealt with this platform so
don't even listen to them. And Dr. Lake,
I think you know this. And that's
ultimately, in my opinion, what this
whole charade is about because you
clearly aren't familiar with my
objections. If you were, you should be
addressing those, not giving a community
college lecture. Again, I'll be looking
forward to those responses, Christopher.
But then he mentioned, like I said
earlier, the temptations of Jesus. That
proves the great controversy because
Satan and Jesus were battling. They were
locked in conflict.
No. Now you're regurgitating the claims
made in the Adventist fundamental
beliefs book again as well as SDA
pioneers like James and Ellen White. The
temptation of Jesus does not demonstrate
that prior to the creation of the earth,
Jesus was exalted to be made equal with
the father, which Lucifer was jealous
of, rebelss, starts accusing the ten
commandments and God's governance in
heaven. is booted to the earth to tempt
the man, succeeds in doing so, and then
Jesus proposes a plan to redeem fallen
man by coming to the earth to silence
Satan's accusations, vindicate the
character of God, showing that you can
too by laying hold of the power Jesus
will give you to do so and siding with
him in a great controversy.
None of that is in the temptations of
Jesus.
These are all details coming from your
prophetus.
You bring your extra biblical paradigm
to the text of scripture, Dr. like
and then you read into these accounts a
bunch of things that are not there. Yes,
Satan tempts Jesus in the wilderness.
That doesn't prove this whole theory.
So, because Jesus was tempted, that
proves the entire extra biblical
pre-earth origin story that Adventist
theology proper depends on for its
survival. Give me a break. It's a
nonsequittor. That doesn't logically
follow.
Like, not at all.
You would never get this from the
biblical text, folks, without bringing
this concept to the text itself.
But Dr. Lake, since you mentioned the
temptation of Christ, how's about
demonstrating this for us from scripture
as well?
Selected messages, book one, page 273.
Quote, "As soon as the long fast of
Christ commenced in the wilderness,
Satan was at hand with his temptations.
He came to Christ enshrouded in light,
claiming to be one of the angels from
the throne of God, sent upon an errand
of mercy to sympathize with him and to
relieve him from his suffering
condition.
He tried to make Christ believe that God
did not require him to pass through
self-denial and the sufferings he
anticipated. That he'd been sent from
heaven to bear to him the message that
God only designed to prove his
willingness to endure.
Holy Toledo, this woman.
So, in the temptation of Christ in the
wilderness, Satan supposedly came to
Jesus and told him, "I'm an angel sent
from heaven on an errand of mercy to let
you know that God the Father doesn't
actually require perfect obedience from
you."
Remember, the SDA church teaches that
Jesus was only a man while on earth.
Folks, the Kosis heresy of Philippians
2, they openly state this on their
website.
that Jesus set his divine nature aside
by incarnating. Notice this is on a page
titled life, death. Uh yeah, that the
sinless life, death, and resurrection of
Jesus under the heading Jesus, the son
of God is born a human on earth.
Philippians 2 6 through8 says that even
though Jesus is God, he set his divine
nature aside and took on human nature.
He came to serve us, to show us God's
love for us and live as our example. He
came to minister to people through his
perfectly obedient life. He obeyed the
father in every way, even when it led to
his humiliating death on a cross.
Close quote. No, he didn't. That's not
what Philippians 2 is saying. It says
that Jesus humbled himself by adding
unto himself a human nature which veiled
his glory
such that when he's walking down the
street, people weren't falling over dead
doing to be due to being in the presence
of incredible holiness
like at the transfiguration where his
glory was not veiled.
Now notice what St. Augustine says on
this paricopy. And if you're an
Adventist and you're new here, yes, we
love the church fathers. And yes, we
cite them regularly because we don't
denude scripture from the church in
history and act as though we're smarter
than everyone else that God has gifted
to the church to help us wrestle through
the text, learn, and grow. I'm not
saying Augustine was inspired, but his
handling of the text nicely explains
what is being said from his commentary
on Philippians 2. Notice
he is said to have emptied himself in no
other way than by taking the form of a
servant, not by losing the form of God.
For that nature by which he is equal to
the father in the form of God remained
immutable, while he took our mutable
nature through which he was born of the
virgin. He did not take on his humanity
in the simple way that a person puts on
clothes as something exterior to him,
like a costume.
Rather, he took on human form in a
manner inexpressibly more excellent and
more intimate than that. The apostle
made it sufficiently clear what he
meant. He was made to appear in human
likeness. He was not exhaustively
reduced to being a man. He rather
assumed the true na uh the true human
estate when he put on the man.
It is not saying that Jesus set his
divine nature aside. This is heresy.
Paul is simply saying that Jesus added
unto himself true human nature.
The incarnate Christ, folks, had divine
attributes ascribed to him. He forgives
sins while incarnate. For example,
scriptures are clear. That's divine. and
only God can do that. So, he wasn't only
a man while on earth. There's a ton of
those. He does all sorts of things that
only God can do, yet they're ascribed to
the single person of Christ.
But that's on their website, that quote
that we saw, because that's what Ellen
White claimed,
which gives us insight into why in her
mind, this interaction between Jesus and
Satan that she is fabricating makes
sense.
Satan comes to Jesus claiming he was
sent from heaven on an errand of mercy.
Uh Jesus is all knowing
while incarnate. Again, that's divine
attribution ascribed to the son while
incarnate. John 16:29-31
uh John 21:17 and many other places
demonstrate this. But in Ellen's mind,
Satan knew that by incarnating, Jesus
set aside what was given to him in the
pre-earth exaltation that made him
jealous and start the great controversy.
She says, "Satan exalted or he he
rejoiced when man fell
because he felt as though he was now
able to pull Christ down from his
exalted status."
And while he incarnated, he was only a
man on earth and set his divine nature
aside.
So, Satan thought he could fool Jesus
apparently by claiming to be an angel
sent from heaven to help him. Further
evidencing why, yes, all of these added
details create problems. They're not
tertiary. Nevertheless, Ellen continues,
"Satan told Christ that he was only to
set his feet in the bloodstained path,
but not to travel it." Like Abraham, he
was tested to show his perfect
obedience. He also stated that he was
the angel that stayed the hand of
Abraham as the knife was raised to slay
Isaac, and he had now come to save his
life. That it was not necessary for him
to endure the painful hunger and death
from starvation. He would help him bear
a part of the work in the plan of
salvation. Close quote.
Again,
to this woman,
I mean, wow. So, Satan supposedly
claimed he was the angel that stayed the
hand of Abraham who was about to
sacrifice Isaac on the altar. and he had
come now to save Jesus's life in a
similar fashion and that he Satan would
help Jesus by bearing a part of the work
in the plan of salvation which is
actually a great irony considering the
SDA church does teach that Satan plays a
a role in the plan of redemption by
being the scapegoat that expedates sins
away. But Dr. Lake, let's see this from
scripture, sir,
cuz that's an actual objection I've
raised from this platform regarding the
temptation of Christ in the wilderness.
This is total fiction, folks.
SDA Church has zero biblical basis for
this, and not a single Seventh Day
Adventist can demonstrate it from
scripture. I challenge any Adventist in
the world.
Get on a stage with me and let's let's
let let's see who is and isn't twisting
things, who's done their homework, who's
lying, who's this. It's easy to make
make comments like that online as a
keyboard warrior without your face being
out there, without your name being out
there, etc.
The reason I stress the specific details
of the great controversy narrative is
because they're foundational to the
framework.
If Jesus wasn't exalted to be made equal
with the father, this whole thing falls
over.
We have zero reason from scripture to
think that Satan began attacking the Ten
Commandments before the earth existed,
leading to God having to vindicate his
character.
But in his attempt to try and only
appeal to the Bible here, we see how Dr.
Dr. Le gives very little of this
narrative. He he he demonstrates very
little of this narrative has biblical
support. He's pretty much already used
every proof text they can. He hasn't
mentioned there was maybe he already he
already mentioned that. I know he
mentions it at some point. There was war
in heaven. Lucifer wanted to exalt
himself and the serpent in the garden.
You're going to run out of proof text,
sir. So, Christopher, in your guys's
response, if you're going to respond to
the the Great Controversy objections,
man, you guys are going to be in
trouble.
Dr. Lake could have very easily cited
The Great Controversy, the book, or
Spirit of Prophecy Volume 1, which is
what that essentially became, Conflict
of the Ages series, and provide the
details. He believes those books are
just as inspired as scripture, just as
authoritative. I know he does because
I've talked with him and I've read his
book. He'll say they're not an addition
to the Bible, but like Uriah Smith said,
they function like a map to navigate the
Bible and and they come from Jesus,
who's the one giving the guidance
through the map.
He said it's clear that the battlefield
of this conflict is planet Earth. And
several evangelical scholars have also
recognized this. So now we're going to
get the standard appeal to evangelical
scholarship to try and add some sort of,
you know, theological street cred to the
SDA church's novel doctrine. He boils
the great controversy down to this
barebones idea that it's just, oh, a
Satan exists who wars against God. And
lots of evangelicals believe that. It's
just obvious. Can't you see it? Who
could possibly disagree with this? Just
obvious, you know, just just read the
Bible. That's the mentality.
Oh, because it gives the impression to
seas that are going to watch this and
think, "Oh, yeah, it is." Because you
all share the same worldview, so it's
obvious to you, but not in reality. When
you take off that lens, Adventist, and
you come out of it, it's so very easy to
see. No, none of this is in the Bible.
This whole thing is predicated upon a
pre-earth origin story that came from a
woman in the 19th century who couldn't
exedute her way out of a wet paper bag.
Oh, it's just obvious. Can't you see it?
Yeah, sure. When you caricature the
belief and make it look like those of us
who have criticized valid issues are
just making things up or don't know what
we're talking about, then sure. But for
anyone that knows this teaching
systematically and has studied it as
in-depth as I have, this isn't going to
work, fellas. It's not going to work
because the teaching isn't just the idea
that there's a Satan who's an adversary
or that there's good and evil in the
world. If this is what SDA scholarship
has to offer, I'm underwhelmed to put it
lightly. We are still waiting for even a
single objection that I've raised to be
addressed. Not the Adventist belief
fundamental beliefs book paraphrased
back to us. He had the opportunity to
show what I highlighted from the fund
fundamental beliefs book and that it can
be supported from the Bible and he
didn't.
Yet, he's literally just pariting that
chapter of the book, folks. That's all
that's happening here. Get the book like
I have on my shelf back here. Read the
chapter. All he's doing is walking
through the biblical citations provided
and paraphrasing it.
He avoided all the extra biblical stuff
they've worked in, the things that I've
actually objected to and is trying to
exclusively use the proof text that that
book uses to make it seem like it's
strictly biblical.
But as we saw, they are grasping at
straws and general biblical details to
then Trojan horse in a truckload of
extra biblical stuff. When you come to
the New Testament epistles, Paul
references Satan several times in 1 and
2 Corinthians and Ephesians 2:2, he
calls the devil the prince of the power
of the air. And it climaxes in Ephesians
6:11 and 12. Let me read that verse to
you. for the famous armor of God. Put on
the whole armor of God that you may be
able to stand against the schemes of the
devil. For we do not wrestle against
flesh and blood, but against the rulers,
against the authorities, against the
cosmic powers of this present darkness,
against the spiritual forces of evil in
heavenly places. The key word there is
wrestle. The term meant handtohand
combat. Christ and Satan are locked in
combat. That's clear through scripture.
But human beings are also in this combat
whether we yield to Christ or yield to
Satan. The two forces back and forth.
The beauty of the Bible is that it's
clear at the very outset. Back to
Genesis 3:15. He will bruise your head.
You shall bruise his hell. The crushing
of the serpent's head is a theme that
runs throughout the entire Old Testament
and into the New Testament,
climaxing in the book of Revelation. And
that head of that serpent is
progressively crushed throughout
scripture. The death blow to Satan was
Christ death on the cross. And then his
victorious resurrection. This was a a
major crushing of the serpent's head.
Particularly his death on the cross. He
defeated Satan. Satan is a defeated foe.
Yet since the cross and resurrection,
Satan knows he is doomed. And that's
where Revelation 12:12 comes into play
and reads, "Therefore rejoice, O
heavens, and you who dwell in them. But
woe to you in the earth and the sea, the
habits of the earth, for the devil has
come down to you in great wrath, because
he knows that his time is short." Ever
since the first advent of Christ, Satan
knows his doom is near. So he is doing
everything he can. And then you come to
the culmination in Revelation 10:20
where the devil is thrown into the lake
of fire. That's the ultimate crushing of
the serpent's head. And I certainly
should add chapter 12 of Revelation
speaks of the war in heaven. So we go
back and forth in scripture. This was a
a cosmic conflict that began in heaven.
Lucifer brought his rebellion down to
this earth. You see that in Genesis 3
and the rest of scripture flows out of
that. But thank goodness you have the
redeemer because the central focus of
the cosmic conflict, it's really the
storyline of scripture, if you follow
the storyline of scripture, I believe,
flowing out of Genesis 3:15, you have
the promise of the Messiah who will
defeat Satan. And the heart of the
Bible, the climax, culmination of the
storyline of scripture is the redemptive
work of Christ at Calvary and in and in
his his resurrection, his ascension,
um his high priestly ministry and his
coming back again, his redemptive work
has and will defeat the devil.
That's quite obvious from a reading of
scripture. Seventh day Adventist
theology simply follows that meta
narrative, that story in scripture of
the conflict between Christ and Satan.
But we must remember that there was a
time before when heaven was all in bliss
before the rebellion in heaven.
again, more filibustering and watering
down the belief to make it seem like
objecting to it is just objecting to the
Bible when no. All he does is cite
verses that the fundamental beliefs book
uses in that chapter on the great
controversy and that's supposed to
justify the whole kitchen sink. So,
because Satan's referred to in the
epistles that proves the great
controversy, Dr. Lake, you sound like a
tauist. You sound like an Eastern
religious figure that there's like the
yin and the yang and the the good and
the evil and there's like this equal
duality that's going on between No.
Ephesians does not say that Jesus is
locked into armed hand-to-hand combat
with the devil as though they're on some
sort of even well, like Ellen said, the
the fallen angels would be given an
equal chance to to measure their might
up against the father's son.
Dr. Lake, show us in the epistles where
we're told that prior to the creation of
the earth, Jesus was exalted to be made
equal with the father. This made Lucifer
jealous and that started the great
controversy.
Show us in the epistles where we're told
that Satan began attacking the ten
commandments in heaven and sought to set
up his own government of self-governance
with the angels in heaven trying to stop
him, but he refused and that's what led
to war in heaven.
Those are the objections that I've made
from this platform, folks. Show us that
in the Bible.
Is it Is that clear?
Show us that in the Bible. You didn't
show us that, sir. You just regurgitated
all the same talking points you guys
have been saying for 180 years.
This is why I constantly say these are
good exercises in in lessons of how to
miss the point and just ramble on. Can
you tell that Dr. Lake is a professor of
preaching of homalytics?
You can tell it in his his cadence, his
talking cadence,
but show us this from the Bible. Not
that there's a Satan, not that Jesus was
tempted by Satan as an adversary. Not
that the Bible describes Satan as a
figure at work on the earth.
Dr. Lake, explain for the audience what
started the great controversy. Don't you
think that's important regarding the
belief?
I mean, that's like the fountain head
claim.
You've alluded to it, but you haven't
been forthright about it. Your
prophetist tells us what supposedly
triggered this. She didn't beat around
the bush. So, let's see it from
scripture since you guys assure us you
only believe the Bible.
No, you don't. Stop saying that.
The SDA church needs to stop lying.
You don't only believe the Bible.
You can huff and puff all you want and
get pissed off and comment down below in
the video in the comments, which I'm
sure SDS are going to do. It doesn't
change the facts.
Stop lying. Stop telling people
Adventism is just a movement of we only
believe the Bible. I used to tell people
this when I was a kid. You know, my
neighbor friends like, "Oh, what's a
Seventh Adventist? Why do you go to
church on Saturday?" You know, these
sorts of things I' then ask, "Oh, you
know, tell them that we we we just Bible
Christians. We believe the whole Bible.
They've been doing this for decades,
folks. They need to stop. They're
lying." No, they No, they don't. They
don't just believe the Bible. Give me a
break. He said, "The climax of scripture
is the redemptive work of Christ at
Calvary, his resurrection, his
ascension, his high priestly ministry,
and his coming back again." Yes. And Dr.
Like Herbert Douglas already told us
that the great controversy theme is the
governing principle over all of those
terms and does the defining for you
guys.
This is a major case of what's called
begging the question. You're assuming
what needs demonstrated.
You can use as much Christian lingo as
you want, but until you get specific in
your definitions of those terms and
what's actually meant by them, you're
not going to be addressing this
platform.
This is why I'm constantly telling
people you have to scale the language
barrier with them, folks.
Because he is veiling all of the issues
under standard Christian lang, you know,
lingo and and phrases to make it seem
like, oh, who could possibly take issue
with this? To make it seem like our
platform is in error when we obviously
don't disagree with Calvary, redemption,
the high priestly role of Christ, or any
of the doctrines that he listed. This
was just a euphemistic catch-all way of
saying that the climax of the Bible is
the system of SDA theology.
It was also an unsuspecting way to
weasle in the investigative judgment in
the sanctuary under the phrase Christ's
work of redemption and that there's a
second phase of the atonement, etc. All
of that is nestled up underneath the
phrase, you know, high priestly role of
Christ. Adventists know this, but
Christians won't. So, Christians that
watch this platform are going to hear
Dr. like say these things and they're
going to be like, "Yeah, I I agree with
the high priestly role." No, they're
defined the definitions are the problem,
not just the words. I've objected to
what they think the high priestly role
of Christ looks like, not that Jesus
isn't a high priest. I've disagreed with
what they think the redemptive work of
Christ looks like, who they claim Jesus
is, and so on. Yet, he isn't addressing
any of those specifics that I've raised,
which is why this response is a
non-response.
Dr. Lake, maybe you aren't aware of
these objections. So, let me point out
some more of them for you since you
listed off all these doctrines. Show us
from scripture that Jesus was
inaugurated to be a priest at his
ascension.
That's what fundamental belief number 24
says in part because he wasn't. as the
great high priest of his people and the
antityypical blemishfree Passover lamb.
He functioned as both the priest and the
sacrifice in the giving up of himself at
Calvary which is prior to the ascension.
Hebrews 21:17 and 18 tells us this as
well as elsewhere. The priest offered up
the sacrifice to God and Jesus was
functioning as the priest at Calvary.
His inauguration as a priest was at his
baptism when the blessing was spoken
over him by the father and the true
anointing not with oil but with the Holy
Spirit was poured out onto him at his
baptism and the father speaking the
blessing over him just like the Levites
had a an oath spoken over them. In fact,
I'd argue Jesus was sprinkled. And I can
make a biblical case for such. They want
to rail against sprinkling. That's one
of the things James White, for example,
absolutely hated. Same with Joseph
Bates. Yeah. Well, I I can prove from
scripture that Jesus was sprinkled
because considering the law required the
sprinkling of the priest in Numbers 8:7
as a part of their sanctifying work,
meaning the priest being set apart, the
consecration.
This happened to Jesus at his baptism to
fulfill all righteousness. And he too
was sanctified, which Jesus himself says
in what?
19. His high priestly prayer.
Again, high priestly prayer. He's
functioning as a high priest in the high
priestly prayer. That's before the
ascension. Sir, he states that he was
sanctified for his people, meaning set
aside just like the old covenant priests
were sanctified and set aside for the
law work. The pattern of the Levitical
priest pointed to Jesus who was the
great high priest and his baptism was to
fulfill all righteousness obviously not
for the forgiveness of sins. Matthew 3.
The point being his baptism was his
inauguration as a priest, not the
ascension.
Yet, fundamental belief number 24
regarding the investigative judgment is
clearly in line with Ellen White who
claimed that Jesus was inaugurated at
the ascension. Yet, no anointing took
place at his ascension. No cleansing by
sprinkling, no consecration like that.
You guys don't understand the high
priestly and kingly role of Christ, a
simultaneous work.
Because MelkiseDC, Hebrews 7:1, was a
priest king, not just a high priest. Yet
your fundamental belief says nothing
about Jesus being a priest king right
now. Only a priest. Because Ellen
claimed at a point in the future in
early writings, Christ is going to take
his priestly garments off and put on
kingly garments. and assume the role of
a king at that point after he ceases
functioning as a priest in
contradistinction to Hebrews 7 which
clearly says he's a priest forever
because this has to do it's tied to his
incarnation and he'll always bear his
body and the marks
these are the sorts of specific details
and objections that I've raised sir not
general waxed over claims of just
Christianes terms show us from scripture
that the day of atonement antipypically
began October 22nd 184 44 and is this
long drawn out process of investigation
exclusively for believers
over and against the plain biblical
teaching that the cleansing of heaven
and earth took place at Calvary where
Christ made peace by the blood of his
cross reconciling himself uh uh
reconciling to himself all things in
heaven and on earth. Colossians 1 uh
19-23.
Show us from scripture that the sins of
penitent believers in the Old Testament
were transferred in type daily into the
holy place to rest until the day of
atonement. You can't because that isn't
what happened. The sins of penitent
Israelites were never Adventists. Catch
this. The sins of penitent Israelites
were never transferred into the holy
place to rest until a once until the the
once a year day of atonement. Leviticus
4 makes this clear. Aside from the day
of atonement ritual, which was once a
year, blood was only ever brought into
the holy place and sprinkled before the
veil on two occasions.
The priest sinned
and when the whole Israelite community
sinned unintentionally.
Those were the two times outside of the
day of atonement. Not on a daily basis
when individual Israelites sinned and
brought their sacrifice for the priest.
Yet you guys by way of Ellen White and
Patriarchs and Prophets page 357 well uh
claims that the most important work of
the daily ministration of the priest was
when individuals would come and bring
their sacrifice. The priest the person
would lay their hands on the sacrifice
in type transferring their sin to the
sacrifice who then would pay the
penalty. And she says that the priest
would then take the blood and bring it
inside the holy place, sprinkling it
before the veil to there sit on record
and stand until the cleansing day of
atonement ceremony. No, that's not what
happened. Yet, you guys have to have
that to make your type antitype work.
While we're at it, show us from
scripture that the millennial reign will
be in heaven for a thousand years, and
those present will be fact-checking
God's work in the investigative judgment
to put people's minds at ease before he
pours out the executive judgment. That's
to say, there's a three-fold phase of
judgment on those raised during the
second resurrection because you guys
include that in redemption as one of the
steps that God is acting out to
vindicate himself. And God vindicating
himself is central to the whole
narrative. While you're at it, since you
included the second coming in your list,
show us this from scripture, too.
The heading of this in heaven, I know
it's a compilation book. Redeem takes
seven days traveling to heaven. We all
entered the cloud together and were
seven days ascending to the sea of glass
when Jesus brought the crowns and with
his own right hand placed them on our
heads.
Show us from the Bible that the trip to
heaven is going to take seven days.
And don't use the pathetic attempt that
Uriah Smith did in his Daniel and
Revelation commentary where he claimed
that Revelation 8:1 says that after the
seventh seal, there was silence in
heaven about the space of half an hour.
And half an hour means seven days in
prophetic time. Therefore, since it was
silent in heaven, that means it's
talking about Jesus coming with the
angels because well, it's quiet there.
So they must be coming with him for the
second coming, which therefore means it
will take seven days to go back.
Yes, folks, that's the sort of mental
gymnastics that they employ to support
this stuff. But those are some of the
actual specifics I've objected to under
the theological categories that he
named. And I haven't heard biblical
support for them, which would silence my
objections. Don't just use Christian
words and phrases.
You need to get into these specifics and
demonstrate them from the Bible.
Especially considering you tried making
the absurd statement that SDA theology
simply follows the meta narrative of the
Bible. I mean, seriously,
did he say that?
Yeah, Dr. O, he did say that. And saying
such a thing is almost hard to even take
seriously.
You guys bring to the meta narrative of
the Bible an outside worldview that is
then read into the things said in the
Bible, which you yourself have done in
this presentation.
It's like f there were so many things
that I wanted to stop and be like, well,
hold up. No, because what he means by
this is this and what he means by this
is this. There was so much Christianes
there
making it seem like, oh, who could
possibly object to, you know, these. No,
it's the way you define those things,
sir. Herb Douglas already showed the
hand in the December 2000 issue of
Ministry magazine. It's up. The jig is
up.
You guys were supposedly given this
paradigm by way of God through your
prophetus. It defines everything.
Righteousness, salvation, gospel, why
Jesus came.
And Dr. Douglas specifically said that
the great controversy worldview,
not just the fundamental belief, sir.
The great controversy theme informs why
Jesus came, what he came to do, etc.
Which is what you've been trying to harp
on this whole time. Well, Genesis 3, it
goes back to Genesis 3:15.
You guys bring this paradigm to the
Bible and then when when the Bible talks
of Jesus coming via the incarnation, you
read into that to silence the
accusations made by Satan from this
pre-ear controversy.
When that's nowhere found in the Bible,
that's not what the Bible teaches about
why Jesus came. Has nothing to do with
Satan.
You read into Genesis 15, the unspoken
idea that the Messiah was coming to
silence accusations from the serpent and
crushing his head is silencing those
accusations. That fallen man can't keep
the law perfectly. So Jesus incarnated
to demonstrate that that isn't true and
went to the cross to vindicate the law
that Satan's rebelling against to show
the justice of God is true and God is
who he says he is and on and on and on.
That's not following the biblical meta
narrative, sir.
It's borrowing the meta narrative to
then Trojan horse in your guys's foreign
worldview that's completely outside of
the Bible.
Why don't you guys just own that, sir?
It drives me crazy with Adventists. They
want to deny, deny, deny, deny.
Everything is a deny.
It is crazy. I'll get SDAs that tell me
I know nothing about SDA theology.
Like, you're not a serious person.
Like I would never say for example Herb
Douglas knows not a single thing about
Christian theology even though I
disagree with Herb Douglas like I know
he's passed now but like on
fundamentally probably 95% of things
because again everything's going to be
defined through the great controversy
but I would never make the silly
assertion because the track record is
there. Yeah. If you think that silly
claim is true go and look at our
website. I know nothing about SDA
theology. Okay. They need to give up the
mental gymnastics and just own it and
defend it like Mormons try and do. Stop
trying to act like, "Oh, we just believe
the Bible. We're just Bible Christians."
No, you're not. But you're not. You're
kidding yourself. I only ever read my
Bible.
Yeah. Okay. You might. You as an
individual might,
but this platform is not about you. This
platform is about addressing the
organization like the mission statement
says. Instead though, instead of just
owning this, like we've only seen about
5,000 times, we have another Adventist
scholar doing the it's just obviously
there in the Bible, but then doesn't
address any of the actual objections,
which are the finer details that is the
engine under the car. Think of it like a
car inspection, folks. Dr. Lake is
trying to is trying to sell a car. He's
pointing to it from a distance to say,
"This car is great. It's just like any
other car out there that's reliable,
strong, durable. But it has its own
unique features like every other car
does.
But when you get close and you pop the
hood, you realize, "Oh no, this thing's
a lemon."
This platform has popped the hood and
we're pointing out the gutted insides,
saying, "Hey, this doesn't align with
the owner's manual, the manual being the
Bible."
And people like Dr. Lake are just
ignoring that and saying, "But look how
pristine the paint job is." Even though
the paint job is a trick, it's it fools
the eye. It's a cover up for the core
issue.
And that without question is what's
going on here. It's not about responding
to answering Adventism. It's about
making it appear that some of the
approved voices of the movement have
addressed our platform, giving the
signal to SDAs that we've been dealt
with so they can all rally amongst
themselves and pat each other on the
back and tell others not to listen to
us. It's not going to work. It's not
going to work anymore.
Just like they do with Dr. Lake's book,
they do the exact same thing. He does
the same thing in his book in his own
book. He dodges the actual criticisms,
denounces all critics as can write
parrots, and then preaches on things
that miss the point and don't even
address the real issue. Then Adventists
cheer and celebrate amongst themselves
and tell anyone with valid criticisms,
"Oh, the SDA church has already buried
those arguments." When in fact, no, they
haven't. They've quenched the
inquisitive minds amongst the movement
to make sure to keep them docile and
unquestioning.
That's what this is about.
And I hope Dr. Lake you don't because
we're going to be responding to his
book. I was planning on actually doing
that and then this came out. So now
we're responding in this format. So we
are going to eventually get to
responding to his book which again is
just I mean chalk full of I've just got
sticky notes full I mean there's some
pages in here folks where it's just like
ab just full of sticky notes. Some page
I can't even read the page anymore. It's
got so many sticky notes on it. That's
the level of effort I'm putting in, Dr.
Lake, to respond to you.
I'm actually going through I assume an
Adventist worldview when I do critiques.
This is the thing. Adventists don't
understand the difference between a
internal and external critique.
They always think you're doing an
external critique. that I'm taking a a
belief that they hold, plugging it into
my own held beliefs, and then showing
why it's wrong based on things that I
already assume and believe that don't
jive with Adventism
when no, that's not what happens. I do
internal critiques on this platform.
There's certain times where I do an
external critique, but it's only in
certain context. An internal critique is
where you assume the worldview of what
you're critiquing and then point out
inconsistencies and flaws within the
system. When I read books like this, I
put my great controversy worldview lens
back on and do my criticisms from there.
Not externally,
but I'm putting in the work to try and
actually respond to them and actually
consume the materials and engage with
what's actually being said. And yet the
response you get is, "Oh, you're just a
Canrite parrot." Yeah, news flash, no
I'm not. I'm not a Dale Ratzlaugh
parrot. I'm not a Dez Ford parrot. I'm
not a Walter Ray parrot. I'm not a
parrot of any other person who's been
prominent that's come out of Adventism
that's then criticized them. At least
not that I'm aware of. They may be out
there somewhere, but I'm not aware of
them. And the people that have been, I
know their theologies, and I don't align
with them on everything. I don't know
any Adventist, former Adventist that's a
prominent critic of Adventism that
agrees with my view on the Sabbath, for
example. And yet, I get all these same
people that comment on the platform, all
these same Antonyomian arguments and all
these sorts of things they've used on
people from 170 years that aren't
relevant to me. They don't even know you
borrowed all your arguments for the
Sabbath from my tradition.
You're just claiming we were wrong about
the day. All the arguments you use, you
took from first day sabotarians is what
I'm saying. So, Christopher Jud, you
guys better have a better response put
together than what we've heard thus far
because if this is it, yes, you guys are
in a lot of trouble because SDAs who are
actually inquisitive, who come over and
check what's going on over here and
check the sources for themselves,
they're going to get redpilled. They're
going to get redpilled and they're going
to be like, "Holy smokes, dude. They're
not responding like at all."
any objective person is going to see
that thus far. Maybe you will at some
point. I I'd love to see it. I've been
waiting for over a decade for you guys
to respond to some of these things.
We're still waiting. He ended by saying,
"We have to remember there was a time
before when heaven was all in bliss
before the rebellion of heaven." Okay,
Dr. Le,
you just said you guys only follow the
biblical meta narrative.
Can you show us from scripture that this
was triggered by Jesus being exalted to
be made equal with the father leading to
a great controversy? That's what we're
waiting for, sir. Any day now. Your
fundamental beliefs book says it. Your
prophetus says it. I've got review and
herald articles that say it. I've got
ministry magazine that says it. None of
them have been able to provide any
biblical support for this. only general
statements in scripture just like you
did war in heaven then all these extra
details are supposedly validated because
of that. Nope, not going to cut it.
These extra details create
contradictions. They twist what the
Bible teaches about why Jesus actually
came, who the true Christ even is,
etc.
So far, this has been rather
disappointing because when I first saw
this, I was hoping we would see some
actual engagement and exogetical work.
You teach homalytics, so biblical exesus
should be right in your wheelhouse.
You're a scholar. You should be
steelmaning something that I've said,
presenting to the audience what my
arguments are to make sure people get
it, like I did at the beginning, and
then giving an exogetical argument as to
why I'm wrong using the historical
grammatical method of interpretation.
the only approved hermeneutic in the SDA
church according to Ted Wilson.
That's not what's happening
cuz I don't think you've done your
homework. I have and I stand by mine. I
know the SDA arguments and I can
articulate them back. It's like it's why
last week, for example, I steelanded the
SDA position on sinless perfectionism. I
know they don't like that term, but I'm
going to keep using it because that's
what it is. I steelmanded the position
on that by laying out the primary source
documentation, explaining how it
functions in the greater system as a
whole, the role that it plays, and then
utilize scholarship that understands the
Greek language. John Owen,
who Dr. Lake, ironically enough, in that
email, you told me how much you love the
Puritans.
What about the prince of Puritans, John
Owen? Is he a qualified source when it
comes to the Greek language?
Yeah, you I know you you I know that you
would agree with that because I know
that you like Jon Oowan.
So I steel the position, explained how
it functioned within the greater system
as a whole, the role that it plays. I
then utilize scholarship that
understands the Greek language to assist
in then using the historical grammatical
method to show why scripture refutes the
SDA position.
That's the regular occurrence on this
platform.
Yet I'm not the one with post-graduate
accolades and fancy letters next to my
name.
Take note of that important fact, folks.
I'm an armchair theologian with a degree
in graphic design.
The guys with Mdives and demons that
teach theology should be waxing the
floor with me. Satan and his angels were
cast out. But then there's that future
hope of a time when the earth is made
new and there will be no more tears, no
more crying, no more evil. There'll be
happiness throughout eternity with God's
throne, his sanctuary established on
this earth, the earth made new. It's the
ultimate underdog story. This earth
where sin abounded will one day be the
very presence of God throughout the
universe, all time, and eternity.
That's what the cosmic conflict is
about. And for the Christian who is in
Christ, it means victory. It means
victory. His victory is your victory, my
victory. That's the hope that the
Christian has. And that is the story
Seabbath Adventists seek to tell. Ellen
White in her cosmic conflict series is
simply following the biblical storyline,
not the other way around.
This is more platon platitudinist like
Christian word salad. The sanctuary will
be established on this earth. Once
again, Dr. Like, thank you for
demonstrating that you guys don't just
follow the biblical meta narrative.
Your great controversy worldview is what
tells you this, not the Bible. The
temple in the new heaven and the new
earth is Jesus,
where the fullness of God dwells bodily,
the incarnate Christ. Revelation 21:22
tells you this. Jesus tells us this in
John 2 when he tells the Jews that the
temple he referred to was the temple of
his body, not the physical building made
with hands. Jesus was the antityypical
temple where God's presence presence
dwells. The temple and all of its
imagery pointed to Christ, not things
that you go through seven steps of the
labor and
the camp and the holy place and the
the temple and all of its imagery
pointed to Christ. He's the bread of
life. That's what the showbread pointed
to. He's the light of the world. What
the manora pointed to. He's the true
temple. His flesh is the true curtain.
Hebrews 10:20. It all pointed to him.
Not a building in heaven, nor a
tabernacle building on the new earth.
But then when he first said this, when
he first said it's the ultimate underdog
story, I had to like stop I like stop I
rewind. I'm like hold up hold up hold up
hold up.
It's truly the the
it's insight into the weak diminished
Jesus figure of Adventism.
Just like he postulated earlier that
Jesus and Satan are in armed combat.
This all is insight folks into how many
SDAs, not all, not all, but many SDAs,
Satan is seen as a formidable foe to
Jesus.
Dr. Lake, this further emphasizes how
you guys do not follow the biblical meta
narrative. Jesus was never an underdog
to the devil.
I I mean, it's just like shortcircuited
when I heard this. I was like cooking in
my kitchen. I almost burned myself. I'm
like, holy, stop what we're doing. What?
No. Was not an underdog story. What are
you talking about?
The creator of Lucifer, who became
Satan, is the underdog in the story of
redemption.
Thank you for demonstrating that the
great controversy worldview informs all
of SDA thought and theology.
But like I said, this was primarily just
platitudinous Christian word salad.
Dr. Lake, if you're going to respond to
this platform, you need to know the
objections we've raised.
Throwing out a Christian word salad
doesn't do anything. For example, his
victory is your victory. For the
Christian in Christ, this means victory.
Do you really think I disagree with
this, dude? On the surface, like,
no, I disagree with what you mean by
that,
which is that Jesus came as the model
man to show you that Satan's accusations
about the law are false, and you can
keep the Ten Commandments perfectly with
God's help, and through Christ's
overcoming, you can be an overcomer like
he was, and also silence Satan's
accusations, vindicating the character
of God in the great controversy. Again,
taking us right back to the pre-Earth
origin story.
Everything that you say, sir, is
informed by that. That's the problem.
That's why SDAs when they comment our
videos and stuff, they're like, "Why are
you picking on one denomination?" No,
you don't get it. This isn't a Christian
denomination. The fact that you can't
see it is the point. That's why it
exists. We're here to tell you and warn
you. It's not Christian.
And the fact that you can't see it is
the problem. That's why in in part, lost
my mouse here. That's why in part this
platform exists
to help wake people up. Theological
alarm clock going on over here. But it
would have been nice to actually hear
some engagement at this level. But we're
still left wanting because you tried to
make it seem like the great controversy
isn't also a world view.
And again, he made the the claim at the
end. He tags on at the end all Ellen
White's great conf, you know, conflict
of the edges series. It just follows the
biblical meta narrative. And then they
just move on to the next section.
Dr. Like, you're kidding yourself. Come
on, man. You're kidding yourself. You're
kidding yourself.
You know that's not true.
Come on, man.
It does not follow the biblical meta
narrative. We just saw Herb Douglas's
Ministry Magazine 2000 at the beginning,
December 2000, where he shows the hand.
Stop bluffing. Stop saying these things
to make other Christians think, "See,
Adventism is just like everyone else. We
just believe the gift of prophecy is,
you know, it's it's a New Testament gift
of prophecy." And no, dude, you guys
have a completely unique view, and it's
all informed by this extra biblical
paradigm that you claim was given by God
through Ellen White.
So, Dr. Lake, you ended up demonstrating
that the claims made on this platform
are valid, and not a single claim that
I've made was successfully challenged.
Adventist might think so. Uh but present
truth does not hold weight under
objective truth. And objective truth is
on our side.
You guys can't demonstrate that the
central component to your entire system
comes from scripture. You can't
demonstrate that because it doesn't. You
know it. I know it. And now everyone
else knows it. Because if the deck were
stacked in the SDA church's favor, you
would have silenced my accusations like
Adventists think they are silencing
Satan's.
So part one, our objections regarding
the great controversy still stands.
So Dr. Lake Christopher, my mind has not
been changed. My objections have uh not
been extinguished, which means yes, the
SDA church is not just in trouble. It's
in big trouble. We're not going
anywhere. People can examine the sources
for themselves over and against what
you've put forth and come to their own
conclusions.
The standard game plan the SDA church
has utilized in the past is not going to
work anymore, fellas. It is a different
era. Information has never been more
easily accessible. Our website is the
most sourced platform that I'm aware of.
If something else exists, God bless
them, but I'm not aware of it. Thousands
of primary sources, folks.
Couple clicks and you can be there at
the source yourself. digging through
review and herald archives, youth
instructor archives, ministry magazine
archives,
sermon, listening to sermons, talks,
books, reading George Knight's search
for identity, FD nickel. I mean, you
name it. Are these all fringe people?
Dr. Lake, we're going to see in part
two, folks. He tries to make this seem
like, you know, these critics, they they
they point to these real uh uh you know,
fringe, you know, no, we're not doing
that here, sir. We don't point to Joemo.
The shooting spitballs from a distance
approach is not going to work. It might
keep Adventists from inquiring and
listening, which is what I personally
think the goal is here, but it won't
stop the truth from pre prevailing over
present truth, aka lies.
to the Adventist Church, her scholars,
all the guys at the BARRI, everyone up
in the SDA Ivory Tower up in, you know,
Tacoma Park. Get your best scholars the
movement has to offer. Let's set up a
publicly moderated discussion, debate,
whatever you want to call it, on this
subject and see who does and doesn't
know what they're talking about. How's
that sound? The formal topic can be, is
the great controversy narrative derived
from scripture?
Should be simple, right? You guys are no
creed with the Bible movement. Let's see
it. Okay.
Let's see it. Send whoever you want.
10on-one.
Send as many people as you want. Bring
your best. Bring everyone you got.
Not a single one of you will get on a
stage with me and debate that.
And you know why. And I know why. In
part two, we're going to hear the
response to the claims regarding the SDA
church having a false gospel. And we
will do the same thing. lay out the
points of contention and then listen for
the objections that I've raised and if
they're addressed and supported from
scripture. As always, until next time,
God bless.